a government Convoy on the road to
investigate a mass murder in the
Democratic Republic of Congo but on
arrival it's met with a furious crowd
pelting it with rocks and demanding
ANW the group wants Justice after
soldiers allegedly shot dead unarmed
civilians in the eastern city of GMA the
government says the investigation is
just beginning and insists it's taking
the matter very
seriously as you know we have just
arrived here in GMA because some serious
incidents happened here which have
caused the deaths of human beings and
other negative things this is why I am
here with this government
delegation many congales have been
protesting for months against the UN
peacekeeping mission that they say has
been ineffective against armed
groups they say the government's imposed
martial law in north kevu and detor
provinces to crack down on Rebel groups
hasn't worked
instead Civil Society groups say
soldiers have been using excessive force
against their own people my son was not
a member of the Rebel group my son
didn't own a gun and we are already
suffering from the armed group's
activities you are unable to tackle the
insecurity why then did you kill my son
who was inside the house my son now is
dead the responsibility of the
government is to protect the civilians
many people were killed without any
reason this is a very bad example which
shows that we don't have a government
that can protect
us the UN is demanding an independent
probe into the military attack the
investigation is expected to take weeks
but for now many families are pressing
the government for the return of bodies
so they can give their loved ones a
dignified burial Imran Alan Al
jazer make sure to subscribe to our
channel to get the latest news from Al
jazer